la fuerza de eta arrasó con las casas de
miles de personas en guatemala que
quedaron atrapadas en los techos y
tuvieron que ser evacuadas en
helicópteros las operaciones de rescate
no han sido fáciles por la destrucción
de algunas carreteras además la
depresión tropical ha afectado a por lo
menos 75.000 personas en el país
centroamericano van a prevalecer las
lluvias hasta va hasta la mañana del
sábado pueda nos quedarían 36 48 horas
de lluvia y después de eso nos va a
quedar un terreno muy alegado con una
sobrecarga de agua muy importante y
vamos a tener tener mucho cuidado con
los deslaves los derrumbes en las
carreteras y sobre todo en un tema de
los puentes que aunque están siendo
golpeados el centro nacional de
huracanes de eeuu advirtió que las
inundaciones continuarán en la región
en honduras ésta ha provocado grandes
inundaciones y deslizamientos de tierra
y me duele mucho
luchando en casita este juguete a cabo
en la calle
es triste por ámbitos
dios tiene que darle algo mucho mejor en
nicaragua decenas de casas fueron
arrasadas y los propios habitantes han
tenido que limpiar los escombros por
falta de ayuda de las autoridades la
tormenta tocó tierra el pasado martes en
nicaragua como un potente huracán de
categoría 4 y fue debilitándose
progresivamente el archipiélago
colombiano de san andrés providencia y
santa catalina también fue castigado por
el poder de la tormenta las autoridades
declararon la zona bajo calamidad
pública los pronósticos del centro
nacional de huracanes de eeuu indican
que la depresión tropical regresará al
mar y recuperará impulso como tormenta y
posiblemente pasará por las islas cayman
cuba y el sur de florida en los próximos
días